as the economic winter looms the cost of
borrowing is rising the bank of England
lifting official interest rates by three
quarters of a percentage point the
biggest single rise in more than three
decades the households already facing an
unprecedented squeeze is probably the
last thing they wanted to hear but the
governor says doing nothing would have
been far worse the economy becomes more
unstable I think we would have much
bigger fluctuations and outputs I think
we would have much bigger job losses and
at the end of the day I'm afraid if we
get into that situation the action that
would have to be taken thereafter to
restore stability would be much larger
and much more damaging so it's critical
that we take the action so the pain is
necessary to prevent something worse at
some point but how does it feel Doling
out that medicine well it never feels
good I don't think anybody should think
that Central Bankers uh in a sense feel
good doing this but it is our job but
the borrowing rate increase wasn't the
only thing there was also a dismal
prognosis for the economy
it is a historic moment not just the
single biggest increase we've had in
interest rates in a generation but one
of the worst economic forecasts this
place has ever produced eight successive
quarters of contraction two years of
recession but here's the thing it might
be better than that it's very uncertain
it could even be worse and that comes
down to the fact that on top of all the
economic issues that other countries are
facing this country has just been
through a financial roller coaster from
which we're only now starting to recover
and what begins in financial markets
often trickles down into the real
economy at this food wholesaler in
London things are not looking good we're
having to put prices up and the
challenge now is there are so many
factors affecting it that
we're almost having to re-cost and
reprice on a daily basis and that feels
like the ingredients of a recession it
does it does feel like it
um that you know that's coupled with the
the pressures on on wage inflation
um you know all of our staff are
concerned about the real value of their
their wages uh and how they're going to
survive through the winter this place is
the Midway point of a food supply chain
that begins in a farm on the other side
of the world and ends in supermarkets
and restaurants that we visit and those
businesses are struggling too last year
a 20 liter drum of oil would cost me
roughly 22-23 pound that same 20 liter
drum of oil now is 42 pounds I can't
pass all that price on things are not
normal anymore the prices are gone
skyrocketed and on top of record Energy
prices higher interest rates and a
recession the government is poised to
add to the squeeze in their Autumn
statement later this month we recognize
the biggest single thing we can do is to
help the bank of England bring down
inflation and the bank is taking its
measures which it's announced today but
the government also has to play our part
by producing national accounts that
balance for the time being though the
Outlook remains tough months if not
years of recession higher mortgages
and higher prices coming your way soon
Ed Conway Sky News